uncharted is an iconic franchise a game
that's firmly cemented to a whole family
of consoles in a series that helped
shape a studio's development and
storytelling and i've never played a
single one
i never had a ps3 growing up the thing
was ugly as sin and the xbox 360 was
king so because of all that i never
picked up uncharted drake's fortune and
not being one to jump into a series at
the midpoint i never played any others
either god that was mumbly i never
played any of the others either i've
always heard that most of them are
fantastic games and i've always been
encouraged to play them with people
appealing to my love of indiana jones
and over-the-top adventure games but
alas nathan drake never graced my screen
that was
until now finally my list of shame will
have one game knocked off it but at what
cost did i have fun do i think it's
worth playing for anyone else who has
never entered the franchise
well i guess you'll find out i will note
however while the game originally came
out in 2007 i am playing the remaster
2015 version because well i don't
completely hate myself but the only
thing that my friends and colleagues
have shared is that the first uncharted
game is by far the roughest entry in the
franchise
the first thing i noticed may be a bit
of a strange one but why does the menu
sound like someone flossing their teeth
with a harp string
it's so abrasive why do i have to lose
10 percent of my hearing every time i
want to pause the game or check out some
of the bonus features
[Music]
but to the actual game uncharted does
this weird thing where it feels like
you've been dropped into the middle of a
story that is also unfortunately quite
thin what is it
come on hold it up
no no no no way deal was for a coffin
that's it we get but the briefest
surface level of hint of what the hell
is going on in the opening cut scene
drake's ancestors empty coffin with a
journal of treasure maps and mysterious
hints documentary filmmaker elena trying
to get a story out of it there's a
shootout against pirates while you're
sporting a wetsuit and sully rolls up
with a seaplane now when things calm
down in the game and sully is properly
introduced the story does expand into
something more tangible into a lost hunt
for el dorado and new discoveries about
the lost city of gold
but that's pretty much it for the first
hour or so of the game there isn't
really much story or character
development or much of anything to
really latch onto narrative wise no word
of a lie i learned more about sully's
gross sexual escapades in the first 20
minutes of the game that i did about
treasure exploration or nathan's motives
or background all right nate just
pretend for a minute that i don't really
care about any of that stuff and cut to
the chase would you
man only interested in the climax he
must be a real hit with the ladies never
had any complaints and that's a shame
because the characters do grow on you
across the game but there's not enough
to latch onto or make you bond with the
characters until your hours in seriously
i tried to count there were at least
three nods to sully shaggin
yeah you weren't too old for that little
bar mate in lima were you
well that was different although i must
admit
equally as strenuous
and one story about him scamming pablo
escobar before one of the most
forgettable villains in video games
history shoots the old boy in the chest
now whoa whoa whoa come on roman
he's got nothing to do
sully
i know he's a big fan favorite across
the franchise now and he does make a
comeback later in the game but boy in
the early hours of the game this guy
loved by fans across the series comes
across like the kind of bloke who posts
boomer facebook memes about hating his
wife uncharted at least broke the mould
for the use of colour palettes for games
of this generation the cliche being that
so many of the titles were shades of
grey and brown at least uncharted
offered a smattering of green and on
average it is way more vibrant than
anything that came out a year or two
before drake's debut to give credit
where credit is due as well the graphics
and style really do hold up in 2022.
again it might be the hd version but
this is the way anyone is likely to play
it these days and for the most part
still looks pretty damn good there are
also some impressive and pretty
awe-inspiring locations like the german
u-boat run around in the middle of the
jungle or some of the old ruins of
colonial outposts later in the game and
most of them are really fun to reverse
and explore and will provide the odd
intriguing puzzle to balance out the
action
nice
ledges and holds aren't too obviously
placed on obstacles in the world which
makes the little exploration you do in
an admittedly very linear game feel all
the more interesting and while you may
be stuck in quite the small levels
having to keep your eyes peeled and
still search for a through line in the
terrain remains satisfying but oh boy
when this system falls it falls hard
for the most part traversal jumping
climbing all feel great but there are
enough moments where it really collapses
that's definitely worth talking about
if you have any memories of playing
early assassin's creed games and trying
to point your character in the direction
you want only to see them jump towards
nothing and crunch against the ground
then you'll know what i mean uncharted
does the same thing there are moments
when you can be certain you're pointing
drake in the right direction but the
game will pull you in some weird angle
and just decide hey you don't land this
jump more than jumping hopping climbing
or exploring though the thing you'll be
doing most is shooting
[Music]
i think the nicest thing i could say
about it is that it's
fine serviceable just about gets the job
done i wasn't expecting anything epic or
too intense as this is more of an
adventure title with third-person
cover-based shooting than it is a cover
shooter but a little more focused on it
may have avoided some issues that i
ended up having with the shooting the
weapons and shooting handle just fine
they feel like they may be a touch weak
but there are also weird things like the
starting pistol doing more damage than
the ak-47 i counted three shots with
your makarov four to five with your ak
it just makes the suite of guns feel a
little unrealized other than a few
exceptions like the thunder of the
desert eagle the dragon sniper dragon of
or shotguns knocking folk into the next
postcode the firearms feel largely
forgettable throughout almost the
entirety of the game unfortunately as
since there is limited ammunition
available i did find myself clumsily
swapping weapons constantly as i ran out
of rounds also what the hell is with the
amount of grenades that get thrown at
nathan drake throughout this game did
the bad guys make a bulk order from
costco or something because they throw
them at you like they're trying to earn
prizes affair i thought i was under
artillery fire
[Music]
[Applause]
yo is my guy using a gun his makarov as
a zip line tool
what
it was around here where i started to
learn the language of the game a bit
more there are moments where it tries to
be a hollywood blockbuster of a video
game one that isn't taking itself too
seriously one that wants to lean into
the over-the-top action of big
explosions cheesy quips
i know i'm not a big-time treasure
hunter like you
but i doubt you're gonna find el dorado
in there
and shotgun blast throwing dudes feet
from where they started
it's happy with it having corny villains
sometimes awkward banter between rivals
is that my deal die now or help you and
die later that's tough call but you know
what
i'll take dino
leaning into movie tropes and leaning
into a bit more of the indiana jones
action romp adventure vibe and the game
really does do those moments very well
indeed
when i was feeling these moments most
acutely i could see why this game has
ended up being a movie but uncharted
keeps countering every win with a
stumble for every big dumb fun jeep
chase through the jungle
there's a bloody jet ski sequence this
time
i drive
okay
i now know that this part of the game is
a bit of a meme among fans and i won't
beat around the bush it [ __ ] sucks
why on earth would you set the scene for
a player to go fast you know the thing
that jet skis are used for that's what
i'm like to do just riding around on my
jet ski and then build a level where you
have to inch forward foot by foot
shooting grenades are bad guys that
blend into the scenery like a solid
bloody snake and destroying or avoiding
explosive barrels that will go boom if
you so much breathe any of the
surrounding atmosphere in which they
exist
sorry i got heared but this part of the
game really got to me like some other
elements of uncharted to me it feels at
odds with itself it gives you the tools
to go fast but then makes you go slow
the game gives you tons of shooting but
makes the guns feel naff it wants to
tell an action-packed story but takes
half the game to make you care about the
three characters that make up its
narrative alright you boys aren't gonna
get all chummy and leave the girl behind
again are you
don't even think about it sully she's
got a mean right hook i'll keep that in
mind and i'll jump ahead here because i
didn't see the vampire zombie twist
coming which in one way is awesome
because it's a twist in the story i
really didn't expect but in another way
it's again at odds with the rest of
uncharted because fighting them is about
as fun as chewing on tinfoil
but wait there's more as the story
develops and you find yourself in an old
german yubo base learning that these
things which are called descendants by
the way are in fact born of a plague
from the el dorado coffin again another
pretty cool story beat as the game dips
its toes into fantasy and the
supernatural in the same way indiana
jones does the thing is though now you
have to fight these bullet sponge
enemies that can melee you to death in
two hits
in tight close quarters corridors
sensational after that slog the good
side of uncharted rears its head once
again as through the rest of the game
you'll find yourself gunning through
levels as mercenaries and descendants
fight each other and through the chaos
you get to lean into the action and
blast through combat in a much more
satisfying and fluid way and this is
consistent
all the way up to the final sections of
the game it's intense it's satisfying
and it's where some of uncharted's
gameplay elements work best we fight the
last area we see the little story beats
that have been drip fed to us across the
six to eight hours come together we
witness that forgettable british villain
get his comeuppance as he's turned into
a descendant and have one more twist as
he's betrayed by his mercenary
right-hand man and then the game gives
you a wet fart of a final boss fight
your enemies numerous your ammo sparse
your cover flimsy the boss invincible
his shot's lethal
the last fight is rubbish and really a
disappointing end to a game that i found
was really finding some momentum and
confidence during its last half
it might not have all been amazing
it was a
damn sight better than this
the gimmick is that you have to count
his shotgun shots before leaning out of
cover and returning fire because you
know nothing says action adventure like
counting to four at last though after
caving the guy's dome in and chucking
him and his cursed coffin into the ocean
i did get the characterful charming end
i wanted because while the characters
were so hard to gel with at the start
the game does enough to make you connect
with them those connections are just a
bit too far in between
quite a day
yeah yeah save the world triumph over
evil
pretty typical
really but there are enough that my
opinions of the characters did do a 180
across the game sully felt more like the
dependable father figure elena felt more
brave and determined bonding with drake
who was now much more lovable you still
owe me one
[Music]
i'm good for it
after seeing both broader character
beats as well as smaller more charming
and personable moments
uncharted drake's fortune is
an okay game and i can appreciate it was
a game made by a studio that previously
had no real experience with this kind of
title and i can also see where this game
left an impression on players back in
2007. uncharted gave me just enough to
make me entertain the idea of keeping
with the franchise and i've had everyone
telling me oh dave two is way better
than one so with that i did play a
couple of hours of uncharted 2 among
thieves
and they're not wrong i heard him
listening
yeah
you're not gonna like this
oh no no you're out of your mind pretty
much every issue i had with one is gone
in two the story starts out much
stronger the characters immediately have
more character about them the gameplay
in action is more engaging and
satisfying and embraces the action movie
style that created the best parts of
uncharted 1. now i'm excited to play the
whole uncharted franchise and sitting
back and writing this script after some
of the wounds have healed i can see the
merits of uncharted drake's fortune
do i think it holds up today no probably
not do i feel a little foolish for not
exploring the franchise sooner maybe a
bit now would i recommend playing
uncharted one today no
you can skip that one maybe
watch a recap or just the first half of
our
uncharted timeline or something now i
hope i wasn't too mean about everyone's
favorite game here i promise i am a
convert and i am very excited to see
where the rest of the series takes me
but i'd love to know your thoughts what
do you think of the game either when it
first came out or if you revisited it
recently and are there any other games
on your list of shame maybe i have a few
more i should visit and play for the
first time as well either way let me
know in the comments or on twitter at
irregulardave and make sure you
subscribe too thanks again for watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you